in dune inhabitants of the desert planet
wear full body outfits called still
suits this chill suit is the ultimate
survival suit the suit captures moisture
and recycles it into drinking water it
is the thing that allows them to live
and survive in this very arid climate
where water is more valuable than oil
than gold jacqueline west and bob morgan
made close to 200 suits for the new
movie let's break down how the still
suits were made and what parallels exist
to nasa's space tech we are recycling
human waste on the international space
station today we recycle urine we
recycle the humidity you own your sweat
let's suit up for the science and design
of dunes still suits
still suit is a high efficiency
filtration system
even this early in the morning you
wouldn't survive two hours without one
of these
on arrakis where most of dune takes
place the environment has become so
harsh that a human being cannot survive
without being able to hang on to all of
your bodily fluids the design team
wanted to be as faithful as possible to
the groundbreaking 1965 novel that the
film is based on we're all such big fans
of the book it goes into so much
descriptive discussions about each
element of the still suit the nose ring
the tubing the water catch pockets the
still suit for frank herbert was a
distillery and it took your human waste
water and by a pumping system that
starts from the heel of the foot keeps
the distillery running in good working
order your suit won't lose more than a
thimble full of water a day
interestingly the designers drew
inspiration not from the space age but
from the middle ages our inspirations
were medieval
nights even the armor you can see it's
replicas of some of the templar armor if
you look at pictures of the medieval
knights everything is jointed everything
is flexible for fighting once they
gathered inspiration and commissioned
sketches it was time to build a
prototype so they turned to the artist
who made suits for the original batman
movies jose fernandez he's actually done
some work with nasa developing new suits
and new helmets so we built the first
prototype for us we actually watched all
the pieces be cut
on the table and talked about does this
look like it would really work we called
our still suit a micro sandwich because
we wanted the different layers to be
visual so netting
over a cotton fabric over a wicking
fabric like an under armour
type of thing that breeze and wicks
water and takes it away from your body
like what they use for the football
players today on the field we used very
flexible materials even for the hard
pieces we knew that our actors are
really going to wear these in those
conditions in the desert and their
bodies would have to breathe
so as a result all suits needed to be
custom made using molds of each actor's
body it's basically three pieces it was
designed in a way that was functional
and easy to put on and off and allowed
us to keep them cool in a very natural
way everything on it conceptually would
function but were they
functional on set no they really had to
get out of their still suits to go to
the bathroom okay so although the
costumes didn't actually recycle an
actor's waist
would a real still suit be possible
someday let's examine how water
recycling works in space on the space
station they have a saying
that yesterday's urine is tomorrow's
coffee when the crew member goes to the
bathroom we collect urine separately
sort of in an air funnel it goes into
the funnel and we add some chemicals to
prevent it from breaking down and making
ammonia and other gases so the crew
members when they exercise and sweat a
lot that all goes into the air and we're
able to remove that humidity from the
air
and put that into the water processor
along with the
water from the urine processor about 50
of the crew members water comes from
urine and about 50
comes from sweat perspiration the space
station acts like one big still suit but
while on dune
your body's movements provide the power
on the iss machinery powered by solar
energy is needed we have electric pumps
electric heaters we have a rotary
separator that spins it so all the urine
goes to the outside we collect that we
add heat and the water boils off at a
low temperature and then we condense
that water clean it up farther and then
we heat it up to sort of oxidize or
remove additional chemicals and then we
add some iodine similar to you might add
when you're camping to your water system
and then it's fit to drink for the
astronauts and make their coffee
sounds efficient and with the brand new
system recently installed on the iss
nearly 98 of astronauts water will soon
be recycled
that seems on par with the dune still
suit but
why is a real still suit powered by our
own bodies still science fiction you
could certainly capture energy from body
movements you may be possible to do some
of it you do the water recovery to
recycle human waste requires a lot of
energy and that's typically more energy
than human body can provide if you took
in 2500 calories per day
you can't generate 2500 calories of work
because the body's only about 25
efficient i don't think it's
thermodynamically possible to do what
they're
they're doing in the suits the still
suits in dune provide a concept of
surviving an uninhabitable desert planet
with all science fiction you know
they're pushing the envelope of what's
possible part of the
imagination and thrill of space travel
is trying to make some of those things
that are science fiction what portion of
them can we make real when people do go
to mars they'll probably wear something
very close to the stool suits this book
was so prophetic i think in la next year
we're going to see a lot of still suits